On
July 20th, 1969, with “one small step,”
Neil Armstrong became the first person to
walk on the moon.
Since that date forty five years ago, the
moon landing has been the subject of intense
study and historical analysis.
From what Armstrong actually said with his
first step to if the American flags the astronauts
planted are still there, mankind’s first
rendezvous with the moon has captured the
world’s attention in a way few other things
have.
Despite this, there are still several noteworthy
facts that have remained obscure after all
these years.
Allow us to bring just a few to (moon) light:
Neil Armstrong was chosen to be the first
person on the moon due to the basic structural
design of a part of the Eagle.
Out of a group of 29 astronauts that trained
for the Apollo mission to the moon, only three
were chosen when the final announcement was
made in January of 1969.
Neil Armstrong, Edwin “Buzz” Aldrin, and
the oft forgotten Michael Collins became the
official crew of Apollo 11.
Immediately, attention turned to which crew
member – Armstrong or Aldrin — would be
the first to walk on the moon (Collins was
the command module pilot and, therefore, was
ineligible).
Even though both men were going to walk on
the moon, it was a great honor to be the first.
In fact, the question was asked at the press
conference and the response was that it had
yet to be decided.
Over the next four months, as the astronauts
continued their training, debate and rumors
circulated among the media.
At first, it seemed that Aldrin would have
the honor.
This speculation came from the precedent set
by the Gemini program, which made ten crewed
flights for the purpose of testing ships and
astronauts to spacewalk.
During the flights, the commander (which Armstrong
was to be for Apollo 11) stayed inside the
ship while the pilot (which Aldrin was to
be for Apollo 11) did the space walking.
Further fueling this thinking was that it
was rumored that Aldrin was actively campaigning
to be the guy.
According to the memoir written by Chris Kraft,
head of Mission Control, “Buzz Aldrin desperately
wanted that honor and wasn’t quiet in letting
it be known.”
In April, only three months before liftoff,
it was announced that Neil Armstrong would
be the first man to walk on the moon.
The main reason NASA gave for the decision
was that the Eagle’s hatch opened to one
side – rather than up or down – and that
side was towards the pilot, Aldrin.
The bottom line was that when the hatch was
opened, the commander, Armstrong, had a clear
path to exit, while the pilot was pinned in
the rather cramped space of the module.
By a sheer happenstance, it made more sense
for Armstrong to exit first.
Plus, as NASA’s heads pointed out, Armstrong
was actually the more senior member of the
team anyway, having entered the program in
1962, while Aldrin came in 1963.
In later years, despite the official hatch
story, some, including Kraft and fellow astronaut
Al Bean of have come out and said that NASA
wanted Armstrong to have this honor rather
than Aldrin because they thought Neil’s
ego could handle it better than Aldrin’s.
So perhaps the hatch design simply gave them
the excuse they needed.
Armstrong’s famed “one small step” line
was pre-planned, at least according to his
brother.
Even until his last breath in 2012, Armstrong
adamantly insisted that his first line was
spontaneous and was only settled on in the
moments prior to the walk.
A BBC documentary released after the astronaut’s
death disputes that.
In the film, Dean Armstrong – Neil’s brother
– tells the story of a note passed during
a late-night game of Risk (yes, the board
game).
In the months leading up to the mission, Dean,
Neil, and their families spent time together
on Cape Cod.
After both men put their boys to bed, Neil
challenged his younger brother to a hearty
game of Risk.
During that game, Neil handed Dean a piece
of paper:
“On that piece of paper there was ‘That’s
one small step for [a] man, one giant leap
for mankind.’
‘He says, ‘What do you think about that?’
I said ‘fabulous.’
He said, ‘I thought you might like that,
but I wanted you to read it.”
That said, both Aldrin and Collins made it
clear that at no point did Armstrong share
his thoughts about what he would say.
Of course, perhaps his brother was an exception.
The second thing said on the moon was a tad
less poetic than the first.
While everyone remembers that first line,
few can recall the second.
That’s because it didn’t hold the same
“oomph” factor.
According to the official Apollo 11 Air to
Ground Voice Transcription, that line was
“And the – the surface is fine and powdery.”
Armstrong continued on this line of thinking,
“I can – I can pick it up loosely with
my toe.
It does adhere in fine layers like powdered
charcoal to the sole and sides of my boots.
I only go in a small fraction of an inch,
maybe an eighth of an inch, but I can see
the footprints of my boots and the treads
in the fine, sandy particles.”
After further discussion about the ease of
movement on
the moon, they began to go back and forth
about Buzz’s placement of the camera and
backlighting.
Exciting conversation, indeed!
President Nixon had an “In Event of Moon
Disaster” speech ready
After the Apollo 1’s tragic fire in 1967
and the unproven nature of space travel at
the time, the safe return of Apollo 11’s
crew was far from an assured thing.
To that point, President Nixon had to prepare
for every scenario when he addressed the nation,
including the tragedy of a “moon disaster.”
So, he had his speechwriter, William Safire,
prepare remarks that are both chilling and
inspiring.
The speech begins with these two lines,
“Fate has ordained that the men who went
to the moon to explore in peace will stay
on the moon to rest in peace.
These brave men, Neil Armstrong and Edwin
Aldrin, know that there is no hope for their
recovery.
But they also know that there is hope for
mankind in their sacrifice.”
Additionally, below the “death” speech
were instructions to what needed to be done
both before and after the address to the nation.
Before, the President should “telephone
each of the widows-to-be.”
Afterwards, NASA will end “communications
with the men” and “a clergyman should
adopt the same procedure as burial at sea,
commending their souls to the ‘deepest of
the deep,’ concluding with the Lord’s
Prayer.”